Donald Trump and Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General have been cleaning
house lately they fired 46 Obama era US
attorneys in order to replace them with
their own picks one of these newly fired
federal prosecutors is Preet Bharara and
he was the US Attorney for the Southern
District of New York which includes
Manhattan what was Barrera and what was
his office doing when he got fired
investigating none other than Fox News
and most of us remember last year when
women started coming out of the woodwork
over at Fox News accusing the company
CEO Roger Ailes of sexual harassment and
assault and there have been allegations
that Fox News failed to inform
shareholders of the repeated past
settlements involving sexual misconduct
by Ailes and other executives and that's
exactly what US Attorney Bharara was in
the process of looking into when he was
ousted by the Trump administration
recall that gretchen carlson sued Ailes
for sexual harassment later megyn kelly
and 25 other women came forward
describing similar experience and 21st
Century Fox hired a legal team to look
into the claims they found the claims
were credible and it ended up with Roger
Ailes leaving in shame from Fox News
they also fired other Fox News
executives who they found sexually
harassed women as part of what was
uncovered to be really a larger culture
Fox News of sexual impropriety wot
whitewashing and just sort of a general
boys club situation we learned about
andrea tantaros who used to be on the
five who said that Fox News quote
operated like a sex fueled Playboy
Mansion like cult and 21st Century Fox
ended up settling with many of these
women for pretty large sums of money
here's where it gets interesting it
turned out that Fox had actually been
settling sexual harassment suits like
this for years before any of them went
public last year and for a while the US
Justice Department was suspicious that
the settlements weren't being reported
to shareholders which are obviously
important for shareholders to know about
and it can even be illegal
to withhold in certain situations so
barreras office did the right thing they
start
a criminal investigation it is now
abundantly clear that Fox didn't report
the settlement to the SEC but now it's a
matter of prosecutors and defenders
sifting through the law to determine if
Fox News was really obligated to report
them and here's the real gem in November
right after the election Trump and
sessions meet with Barrera and they say
listen you're doing a great job they
commended him they said we want you to
stay on even though you were appointed
by Obama we want you to stay on that's
before it was known that he was
investigating Fox News now everybody
knows that Barrera had been leading the
DOJ inquiries into Fox News's SEC
filings and Trump is firing him and
here's where it goes from a gem -
absolutely crony istic nonsense Donald
Trump is reportedly considering
replacing Brora with mark mikaze mark
mikaze is Roger Ailes his personal
lawyer who helped Ailes get through all
of the harassment cases you've got
Barrera who's well known for fighting
corruption in New York you've got McKay
Z who's known for defending serial
sexual assault or Roger Ailes and the
idea is replace Bharara with McKay Z I
wonder if the Fox News probe would be
affected by replacing Barrera with McKay
Z I don't know is this just a middle
finger from Trump to anybody that's
causing trouble for what has become his
de facto propaganda machine is there
more here in terms of handpicking a
state attorney for the Manhattan region
which of course is where Trump has done
business for decade after decade is
Donald Trump doing a little quid pro quo
scratch Fox News's back so that they'll
report better on him as Donald Trump
would like to say we would at least get
the impression that an appointment of
McKay Z would be a quid pro quo either
by trying to derail the Fox News
investigation or maybe nepotism by way
of Rudy Giuliani who's still a close
non-salaried advisor to the White House
who's connected to McKay Z this is a
question that keeps coming up and I've
asked it before
if Donald Trump's actions aren't because
of crony capitalism and quid pro quos
they look just like it and I've applied
this to the Russia situation I've asked
before if Donald Trump were a Russian
puppet what would it look like it would
look exactly like the real world if this
entire Bharara McKay Z thing were a quid
pro quo what would it look like it would
look exactly like this and this is a
story that it's gotten some pickup in
independent media outlets and it's
really a micro story of the broader
crony capitalism but also the way a
quote crony corruption I should rather
say not capitalism although certainly
capitalism is an aspect to this when you
consider the for-profit predatory
capitalistic nature of a company like
Fox News but it's also a sort of a
cautionary tale about how even when
we're focused on the big top level
corruption that goes on so much of what
a white house has the ability to do to
swing things in their favor and really
just make all sorts of buddy-buddy
appointments happens at levels where we
often don't pay attention including US
state's attorneys like for example in
the Manhattan region so we're going to
continue following it we'll figure out
whether mikaze ultimately is appointed
to replace ferrara which would just be I
mean laughable in terms of the impact
that it would have today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made possible
in part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription into I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is control
by very few corporations that keep the
prices very very high even over $300 for
prescription glasses with Warby Parker
they started just 95 bucks mine cost
that including lenses and for every pair
sold they give a pair to someone in need
so to try the five pairs and support the
David Pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS